alors ça audiard on l'a vu vous êtes
très très italienne donc on va vous
faire une interview
[ __ ] claudia est ce que comme une vraie
italienne vous êtes jalouses non est ce
que comme une vraie italienne vous aimez
bien les machos j'aime les foules et les
mecs oui je suis comme une vraie
italienne êtes possessive avec votre
fils pas du tout
ah oui pad il fait ce qu'il veut moi mes
enfants ils ont vécu tout seul à 14 ans
ah oui je leur ai dit toute la liberté
parce que je suis une femme libre un
mois c'est pas un peu temps 14 en bas je
pensais que c'était bien
est ce que comme une vraie italienne
vous faites sécher votre linge aux
balkans n'ont fait comme une vraie
italienne êtes fiers de vos rondeurs
numéro d'art mechita ronde s comme est
ce que comme une vraie italienne vous
êtes laissé un petit peu aller quand
vous devez été mariée je me suis jamais
marié d'abord est ce que comme une
veille des aliens ou manger des pâtes
tous les jours non je mange très peu je
marche comme un petit oiseau presque
comme une brave monsieur nous est
croyante
oui jacques attali qu est-ce que vous
finissez toutes vos phrases par
vaffanculo non ça je peux le dire c'est
pas habituel quoi c'est pas oui et c'est
comme une vraie italienne où un membre
de la famille dans la mafia
non non vous avez un grand frère qui est
un peu trop protecteur non non c'est moi
qui n'ai je suis comme une vraie
italienne de le stade le dimanche
j'adore le foot est ce que comme une
brique aliens vous tombez dès qu'on vous
bousculent dans la surface de réparation
non je ne tombe pas
acadia cardinal mes étoiles c'est publié
chez michel lafon de free au théâtre
dans 12 autres je laisse au théâtre de
la madeleine
m
et